so chrissy teigen just happened to be a
BuzzFeed as I was writing this post and
I told her your eggs in a win and she
said god damnit and she just walked away
today I'm gonna be making five famous
scrambled egg recipes to find out which
one is actually the best I set up five
recipes to replicate exactly how the
celebrities do it we have Gordon Ramsay
Martha Stewart Heston Blumenthal Anthony
Bourdain and then for a wild card
I have Chrissy Teigen I lined up all the
ingredients all the recipes I measure
them precisely and I got toast ready for
all of them so we can all try it so the
whole playing field is completely level
three my friends are gonna come down and
taste them with me to see which one is
actually the best so let's get the
scrambled egg showdown crackin Anthony
Bourdain's
eggs he whips them just until there's a
ripple of white and yellow not all the
way and then he cooks them in a hot pan
with butter and he cooks them in a
figure 8 motion until they're cooked and
this one cooks really fast Martha
Stewart follows a pretty traditional way
to scramble her egg this cheap thing
said if you have good eggs you me they
had anything to them so she could swim
in a pan with butter on low heat
very traditional and she pushes them all
towards the center in this uh ripple
motion to create kind of these ribbons
that are like really beautiful and then
she seasons with salt and pepper right
at the end and that's it
[Music]
Gordon Ramsay's internet-famous eggs
cooks I'm in a pot and he serves them
with chunks of butter and he puts him on
a low burner for 30 seconds he takes
them off
he serves them for 20 more seconds and
puts them on for 30 seconds it's on
again
for last 20 seconds and throw some creme
fraiche in to cool him down really
quickly and that's it because he's
taking scrambled eggs
I'm guessing obviously gonna be good
because if it's a whole quarter cup of
cream in them and she cooks in with
three tablespoons of butter so it's just
fat on fat she cooks him on super low
heat and this takes about 20 minutes
it's so low heat actually she seasons
the egg mixture itself so I think these
ones we're gonna taste like butter and
cream so there'd be pretty pretty good
[Music]
messin Blumenthal has a very strange
method when he combines milk cream eggs
salt and pepper in a double boiler at
the whisk and he puts them over gently
simmering water and just stirs them with
a rubber spatula until they're just
barely cooked the gentle heat is
supposed to keep them pretty soft and
moist and I'm so sorry for using the
word moist it's whatever it's literally
whatever it it's very flat looks like it
was like on the bottom of a pan and it
just like straight down yeah yellow
yellow yellow yeah it's like not very
mix your standard there okay I can see
how he got this texture cuz he has that
like figure 8 technique so like it's
like not mix very well don't do the
figure 8 don't know figure 8 these are a
little like richer the last one was like
anybody making those eggs this one was
like probably your friend who's like oh
yeah
no can whip it up and you're like oh
cool things Martha this is like which is
like what Martha does go hard to start
oh that's all butter
but I know there's not this is what I
would eat you and I'm like I've been
good all weekend like gonna splurge on
breakfast Gordon I can see it though
Gordon
yeah Alex the master I think this is
diner cause you got my favourite eggs no
muss no fuss
really maybe a little bit of milk but
that's it okay see I can see that this
is butter oh my god the cheese or cream
these are good I want this recipe
[Music]
fine-dining chef in the UK I could eat
all this so on the count of three let's
say who our favorite was okay
ready three two I've been little dog are
you kidding me oh my god it had like
texture it was
we love you Houston Chrissy we still
love you about your except
[Music]